hey everybody Michael Knowles here you
know that pop culture music Maven my
producer Mr Davies has insisted that I
maintain my tradition of reviewing every
single NF song that has come out why I
don't I don't exactly know I don't know
why Mr Davies insists upon it since I
listen to so little pop music maybe it's
so that I've reserved all of my my music
analysis powers and I can just totally
laser focus them on what is now one of
the biggest songs in the country
currently number seven on trending
YouTube music so NF
take it away with happy
dear God please
hear me out I know it's been a couple
years musically I like this a lot better
than this other stuff
out and said hello I bet your wondering
why
why I can't
keep obsessing on and stressing all the
little things
when I
foreign
like I don't
care what they need
help with I just can't imagine
I was happy very insightful
foible of humanity is sometimes the
problem is not that we don't know what
happiness is or what a virtuous life is
or what we should do usually we know
what we should do and usually we do know
what would make us happy but
virtue advice or habits and the more you
do either of them the harder those
habits are to break and when you engage
in a habit long enough it just becomes
your identity and you can't divorce
those actions from who you view yourself
to be because we're incarnate creatures
in time and space and so what you do it
shapes and and really constitutes who
you are so you look at it you say I know
this would be a better way of life if I
did this that or the other thing but I
just don't
that just isn't me that just is I'm just
going to be cynical you see this with a
lot of people who are always negative
about everything and they just complain
about everything and they like it they
like complaining they know it makes them
miserable they just that's just that's
just Jane's personality is James just
always cynical and wry and sarcastic and
complaining about everything and so if
you if you stop doing those things which
make you miserable well then who would
you be that's the fear would I lose
myself this is the real Pitfall of our
modern culture that says you've got to
be authentic people are are too obsessed
with being authentic because you can be
authentically miserable hi I'm Zach hi
I'm miserable
plenty of people who do all sorts of bad
things well if they do those bad things
they're being authentic to who they have
been if they break those bad habits
they're being inauthentic to who they
have been but the thing about habits is
the more you just do the good habits and
not the bad habits that's more of who
you're going to be and then the
authentic you is going to be the happier
better version you shouldn't be pursuing
authenticity in as much as you shouldn't
be pursuing yourself a man wrapped up in
himself makes a small package indeed
you've got to be pursuing the good and
then your pursuit of the good
is going to reshape who you are in a
better way it's going to build you up we
are what we worship keep going yeah
business way so long it feels like
something's off when I'm not depressed I
got some issues that I won't address I
got them bad
means I should put the rest I got some
traumas that I can't forget I got some
phone calls I've been avoiding some
family members I don't really connect
with some things I said I wish I
wouldn't now let's live some herbal
Words I Never Shoulda let my lips some
bridges burn I'm not ready to rebuild
yet some insecurities I haven't dealt
with yes I'll be the first to admit that
I'm a lonely Soul win the last two admit
I need a hand to hold losing hope headed
down a dangerous road strange I know but
I feel most at home when I'm
I like that the cigarette onto the
birthday candle
truthfully
open up
and asking for me out this hole I'm
trapping
the truth is
I was happy
don't know what's around I don't know
who I'd be if I was happy put put a
pause there because this clarifies
something that I just said in precisely
I just said we are what we worship but
obviously it's not literally to you
don't become a one-to-one of what you
worship but you do become more like
what you worship he says I can't imagine
what I would be like if I was
happy it just that that hap it seems so
distant from him it seems so foreign
from him you can't bridge that golf so
if if we worship God we're not going to
become God
but there is something mysterious going
on and you see it written in the New
Testament when Saint Paul says it is no
longer I who lives but Christ who lives
in me that we we do become more like
what we worship and
we we do participate in some way
and we are participated in by what we
worship I mean this is the the Sim the
symbolism of the mystical Body of Christ
the the community of Believers the I'm
just talking about this from
specifically a Christian perspective but
it's true of all these things that we
worship it's true even you know when
people say you are the average of The
Five People You spend the most time with
it's a little bit of folk wisdom and
it's true it's largely true so he says I
can't imagine what I would who I would
be if I was happy that just represents
an anxiety and a servile fear I don't
want to lose myself why not what are you
holding on to the people in this music
video are miserable there's some good
stuff going on but it's it's all colored
and discolored by this misery don't hold
on so tightly to this miserable thing
just because it's yours if you let go of
that
you you can quite simply
have something that's much better I
don't know what my future is
but I can't keep on living in
living in my Agony watching myself first
thing go up in Flames acting like I
don't
care with anyone else thinks when I know
truthfully that that's the furthest
thing from our
time
I was happy
please
if I was happy
kind of ambiguous visuals going on
because you're seeing these
contradictory images coming up which is
even in the lyrics that he's saying is I
can't imagine who I would be if I was
happy but then you do see these glimpses
of happiness because you can imagine it
somewhat maybe it's a little bit fuzzy
but you can you have that that intuition
so then the question is do you have the
courage to do it because to pursue that
happiness is to give up what you
currently possess but what you currently
possess isn't all that great so go for
it I really I like this song more than
his other songs one because it's it's
musically a little bit catchy or a
little bit poppier a little bit more
melodic as usual with his songs there's
there's a lot of insight in it a lot
more insight than a lot of pop music
okay that's it
I was happy